so interestingly enough in south
carolina
legislative votes they counted
legislative votes by
voice vote all in favor say aye all
opposed
the eyes have it but one day there was a
piece of legislation that was read
across the desk that would give
legislators pay raises
all in favor say aye all opposed silence
and they passed it and yet to this day
you can't find one legislator that said
they voted themselves a pay raise
republicans you don't say republican
house republican senate
i went to our republican speaker of the
house and i said this is why people
don't trust
us and i filed a piece of i filed some
legislation that said anything important
enough to be debated on the floor of the
house or the senate
is important enough for people to have
votes on the record
so the speaker pulled me aside and he
said put the bill away
we don't need to have it we will decide
what the public needs to see and what
they don't
so let's let's back up for a little bit
when did you decide to go into politics
and and i guess more importantly why did
you decide to go into politics
i was never that political kid i never
cared about politics
in high school i was never in student
government not in college republicans
i had started doing the books for my
family business when i was 13 and didn't
know that wasn't normal until i went to
college
but really when times were tough i
learned how to stretch a dollar i had to
figure out what we were going to pay
and what we weren't and when times were
good we never celebrated because you
knew bad times were going to happen
again
ended up going to clemson go tigers
graduated with a degree in accounting
and then worked for
a company and six of its subsidiaries as
the accounting supervisor
and then i got tired of working for the
guys down the hall and so
we came back home to the family business
and one day i was complaining to my mom
about
how hard it was to make a dollar and how
easy it was for government to take it
and she said quit complaining about it
do something about it
i did not know you weren't supposed to
run against a 30-year incumbent the
primary
i truly didn't ignorance is bliss but
once
um i realized he was related to half the
district and i had thrown my head in
the only option was to win so my husband
got in the driver's seat
i was in the passenger seat we put our
two little ones in the back seat and i
started knocking on doors
and was able to win that state house
seat and truly it was
i thought there were way too many
lawyers at the state house and they
needed a really good accountant
yeah so then that was just the beginning
of your political career really so when
did you
decide to take the next step so
interestingly enough
in south carolina legislative votes they
counted legislative votes by
voice vote all in favor say aye all
opposed
the eyes have it but one day there was a
piece of legislation that was read
across the desk that would give
legislators pay raises
all in favor say aye all opposed silence
and they passed it and yet to this day
you can't find one legislator that said
they voted themselves a pay raise
republicans you don't say republican
house republican senate
i went to our republican speaker of the
house and i said this is why people
don't trust
us and i filed a piece of i filed some
legislation that said anything
important enough to be debated on the
floor of the house or the senate
is important enough for people to have
votes on the record
so the speaker pulled me aside and he
said put the bill away
we don't need to have it we will decide
what the public needs to see and what
they don't
and i remember going to my husband that
night saying if i can't even get
legislative votes on the record what am
i doing here
and he said then fight so i went around
the state of south carolina
and said did you know of all the bills
passed in the house only eight percent
are on the record
did you know of all the bills passed in
the senate only one percent was on the
record
so if you didn't know how your house
member voted 92 percent of the time
if you didn't know how your senator
voted 99 of the time
how did you know who to vote for when
you went to the polls the people of
south carolina were shocked
now to put this into perspective my
first year in office i was chairman of
the freshman class
my second year i was majority whip my
third year i was on a powerful business
committee my fourth year i was
sub-committee chair of banking
the year that i didn't put the bill away
they stripped me of everything
wow i was completely blackballed i could
take the well
no one would listen i could sponsor a
bill
no one would co-sponsor so i ran for
governor
and one of the first bills we signed
into law is now in south carolina
everything debated on the floor in the
house and the senate has to have a vote
on the record
and we took it a step further and did
every section of the budget as well
and you had a pretty solid record in
south carolina
you're pretty proud of that right yeah
that's very proud i mean we went from
a 13 unemployment rate to
the fact that south carolina didn't have
any industry
all our jobs were in the textile market
and they had all gone overseas
and we had to wake south carolina up and
so i went in there and said if you're
costing a person or business time you're
costing them money that's no longer
acceptable in south carolina
and we got to work and by the time i
left we were building planes with boeing
more bmws than any place in the world
five international tire companies
the largest carbon fiber producer in the
world
they were referring to us as the beast
of the southeast and
i loved it and no unions i was a union
buster the whole time
if there was a company that wanted to
come in that was unionized we
we strong armed them and said we don't
want you so
what would you say your guiding
political principles are because it's
interesting to me like
you're 13 years old doing the books so
like there's numbers and those things
matter and now we live in this bizarre
time where everyone's like
2 trillion for this and i just saw this
morning they want they want to pass
another 80 billion to fortify the irs
like what like does anyone look at math
anymore did calculators exist
like what's going on here but but did
you have a sort of guiding political
principle
like when did that sort of all come
together i mean i really think at 13.
i mean i learned the value of a dollar
yeah and i learned that that dollar you
can only stretch it so far and so
really understanding the value of a
dollar appreciating small
and limited government so that people
can be successful without government
getting in the way
understanding the importance of a good
education and that education not being
government responding to money but
government actually responding to kids
and allowing families to decide their
education
and then allowing job creators to do
what they do best which is create jobs
you know if you give a small business if
small business
makes money they don't go on vacation
they hire more people
and so the goal is you want small
businesses to have cash flow so they can
spread the tentacles out
and do that you want a strong foreign
policy where you're
you know making sure you're safe
overseas and it's not coming here
these are basic principles it's not
rocket science
but it's core values that i think are at
the heart of the republican party
but they're at the heart of a good
america too if we do it right
yeah so what was it like the day you got
the call let's flash forward a little
bit the day you get the call
would you like to be the ambassador to
the u.n i can only imagine because it's
there's a very legion of doom scary
feeling over at the university you know
the thing people don't know is donald
trump and i knew each other before
when i won the primary for governor the
first time
i got this envelope with this great gold
trim
and in it was a support check and there
was a note that said you're a winner
and so i got on the phone and we chatted
and we um
were acquaintances throughout the years
and then
2016 happened and um
we had a great slate of talent on that
stage
i put my name behind a different horse
wait who'd you back originally rubio
okay and then that's when trump
tweeted um nikki haley's embarrassment
to south carolina
and i turned around and tweeted bless
your heart so
we always had a great respect for i knew
if you kicked him he kicked back he knew
if you punched me i punched back
you know and so there was a respect
there and but after the primary i
i threw all my support behind him and he
won so
when we got the call reince priebus said
he wants to talk to you about
um you know us he said don't say
anything u.s ambassador to the united
nations
i said right i don't even know what the
united nations does i just know
everybody hates
it yeah and so he said well he's going
to call you so when he called me
he said all right nick are you going to
do this and i said well
i said there'd have to be some changes
and he said what i said well
i've been a governor i don't want to
work for anyone else i would want to
work directly with you so i'd want to be
a cabinet member
he said done i said well i'm a policy
girl so i'd want to be in the room when
decisions are made
so i'd want to be on the national
security council he said done
i said well i'm not going to be a
wallflower or talking head i need to be
able to say what i think
and he said nikki that's exactly why i
want you to do this and he was true to
his word from the first day to the last
day we had a great working relationship
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics
watch our full episode playlist all
right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell